calles y negocios vacíos la vida
cotidiana en kiev se ha transformado
radicalmente en los últimos días desde
que se desató la guerra mientras el
ejército ruso accedía a la capital
ucraniana son pocos los que se atreven a
salir de sus hogares si todos subimos de
la ciudad quién va a defender nuestra
tierra nuestra patria nuestra familia
las alacenas de esta farmacia están
desocupadas su dueña denuncia la falta
de medicamentos y las huellas de la
guerra se hacen visibles en cada esquina
cerca de kiev en el suburbio de irbin el
panorama no es diferente el viernes el
humo negro se expandía en medio de los
escombros
mientras los habitantes preparaban sus
casas para hacer frente a los cada vez
más frecuentes ataques rusos y los
estruendos de las explosiones resuenan
con frecuencia
la guerra ha cambiado los planes de los
ucranianos
teníamos muchos planes habíamos
reservado un estudio para grabar
queríamos grabar la canción el viernes
pero como pueden ver no lo hemos podido
hacer
desafortunadamente vivimos en estos
tiempos nos enfrentamos a estos
problemas que llamaron a nuestra puerta
y tenemos que estar allí y defender
nuestra casa
para muchos la situación se ha vuelto
insostenible algunos deciden marcharse y
comienzan su travesía caminando otros lo
hacen un automóvil así se veían las
salidas de lucha en las cercanías de la
capital mientras tanto el gobierno
ucraniano asegura que las fuerzas
armadas de su país siguen luchando para
liberar las ciudades de la presencia
rusa y aseguran que moscú no ha
respetado el alto el fuego pactado entre
los dos países